Hello, Conan O'Brien here.
All last week, it was
my morsel of television,
to hear black voices as we struggle
with this intense period of
racial anguish and upheaval.
I'd like to continue that tonight.
Earlier today, I spoke with the mayor
of St. Paul, Minnesota,
Mayor Melvin Carter.
He is at the epicenter
of this national crisis,
and he has a unique perspective.
So without any delay, let's get started.
While George Floyd may be the most notable
African American to have died
at the hands of Minnesota police,
he was not the first.
In 2018, tonight's guest was elected
the first African American
mayor of St. Paul, Minnesota,
two years after the
Philando Castile shooting
in the neighboring suburb of St. Anthony.
He's a fourth generation
resident of St. Paul,
and the son of a former
St. Paul police officer.
I'm very honored to welcome
Mayor Melvin Carter.
Mayor, thank you for being here.
I know you're busy, this
means a lot to us, thank you.
Thank you for having
me on, I appreciate it.
You know, we'll start
for me to just ask you
personally how you're doing,
you, your family, everyone doing okay
during these insane times?
You know that's a super
loaded question these days,
and I think some of it
depends on what you mean
and some of it depends on what the day is.
We have a pretty big family.
We've got a crew of children
in and out of the house,
who have been trying
to socially distance--
You know social distance learning at home.
Right, right.
And that's been fun,
as fun as it has been for everybody else.
We've got a three-month-old at home.
Yeah, I want to talk about that.
You have a three-month-old,
so in the midst of
this incredible turmoil, not just COVID,
but all of the unrest and anguish
of the past week and a half,
you have a three-month-old.
That's right.
And so, I just
want to say you're welcome
to come stay with me.
Yeah, right, I appreciate that.
See, try as I might, she doesn't have
the proper appreciation
yet for the term mayor.
I try to convince her that like,
one day this will mean a lot to you,
so like, let me get some
sleep, but no, it doesn't work.
You're not getting the respect you should.
Well, let me start,
because one of the reasons
I really wanted to talk to you,
and again, I am so appreciative that you
could make the time for us, is that
you're kind of, because
you're the mayor of St. Paul,
and also the son of a police officer,
and you are at the nexus of so many,
you know, points right now.
Right.
And your point of view, I
think, is incredibly valuable,
obviously, and so I wanted to start
by talking to you, I
mentioned it up front,
the Philando Castile
shooting several years ago,
which was another horrific incident
which was caught on video,
witnessed by a lot of people.
You had a personal
connection to that incident.
I know it happened in a
neighboring jurisdiction
just outside St. Paul.
That's right.
You knew Philando Castile, is that true?
Not well, I would see
him around community.
He graduated from my same high school
a year away from my younger sister,
a year ahead of my younger sister.
The school he worked at
was the school that my children
went to kindergarten in,
and so he was around community.
I would see him at the coffee shop,
and I would see him
around community events,
but didn't know him well, but of course,
it's really traumatic
for our entire community
for something like that to play out,
and while the rest of
the world was kind of
battling with this major
kind of sociopolitical thing,
we were, locally,
explaining to our children
what happened to Mr. Phil,
so it was traumatic on a bunch of levels.
Right, right, it was a
person in your community
that you knew.
That's right.
And now that event,
obviously, very traumatic,
and got a lot of attention,
but George Floyd seems to, obviously,
has blown this wide open,
and been just
an incredibly wrenching moment
for a lot of Americans,
probably exposing a lot of us to a reality
that we were not aware of,
but you grew up in this reality.
Yeah.
You grew up,
your father was on the police force,
but also you had,
I'm guessing, interactions of your own
with maybe being pulled over, or--
Definitely.
Treated differently
because of the color of your skin.
Yeah, without a doubt.
You know, to the video of George Floyd,
I mean, unfortunately
we've had this conversation
for years now, which is how bad
does a video have to be?
You know, how egregious
does it have to be?
How obvious does it have to be
for us to say okay, wait, that's enough,
somebody's gotta be held
accountable for this?
And we said that after
Philando Castile was killed,
and like, okay, this clearly,
for it to be this obvious, it's clear
that somebody has to be held accountable,
and then we saw that officer acquitted,
and so it seems that with each video
it keeps sort of testing the limits
of just how much that
somebody can get away with
with regard to taking a
black life or a brown life.
Yes, I've had lots of experiences,
you know, frankly, good and bad, right?
I have the privilege,
it's a level of privilege
to grow up with my dad
being a police officer,
so I had this, my first car was a 1984
two-tone gray Monte Carlo, right?
It was very sweet in a way
that only 17-year-old boys
can truly appreciate.
Yes, I know what
you're talking about, yeah.
Right, right.
And so I'd get pulled
over all the time, right?
And when I got pulled over,
they'd run my plates and
they'd run to my father,
who was in internal affairs at the time,
and I would get let go
with a warning, right?
But you're right, part of my truth is
you shouldn't have to be
a police officer's son.
You shouldn't have to be a college student
or a city council member,
or somebody special
to be treated with basic dignity.
I think Van Jones said it really well
in your conversation with him is that
the trauma of the violence
of that George Floyd video is that
it cracks all of the remaining solace
that we take in those conversations
that we have with our children about
if you just behave, if you just
do everything that they say,
if you just don't resist,
then you'll be able to kinda walk out of
that conversation safely.
He did all of those things, and I tell you
maybe the most heartbreaking
part about that video
is the paradox that he didn't even fight
to try to breathe for his--
To try to fight, to struggle
for his last breath,
but we all know that if he had,
that struggle would have been used
as the excuse to cover up the fact
that he was killed in the way that he was.
Now we're at this national moment today,
very much the conversation
and the conversation
over the weekend, and last
night many demonstrations
have been about the police,
and I'm sure
you have very strong opinions.
There's people out there that,
there's a big movement
to defund the police.
Yeah.
And I would imagine
that like many things, it's complicated.
It's probably a very complicated question.
When you hear about defunding the police,
there are many people, including myself,
who don't really know what that means.
Sure, sure.
I'll tell you what I
think is not complicated
is the fact that we've
bought in to this notion,
this myth, that public safety is just
as simple as police, prisons,
and prosecutors, right?
And every time we feel uncomfortable,
or every time we feel unsafe as a nation,
we can find billions of
dollars to double down
on police, prisons, and prosecutors,
yet it hasn't worked.
We still don't feel safe, you know?
And one of the truths I think
we have to grapple with is
the reason we don't all feel safe, Conan,
is because that public safety framework,
that model, really isn't designed
to make us all feel safe.
It's designed to draw a circle
and protect or insulate the
people inside the circle
from the people outside of
the circle at all costs.
It creates a level of resentment
from the people who feel like
they're outside of the circle.
It definitely creates a
feeling of being threatened
by the people inside the circle,
'cause it's clearly a tenuous balance,
and then we drop our police officers
right in the epicenter of all of that
in a way that community members
are gonna look at them as you're the force
that's kind of here to keep me out
of the greater prosperity of
kinda the broader community.
And so, as we talk to our police officers,
and we hear them say all the time,
we don't have the
capacity or the expertise
to be the social workers,
the mental health counselors,
or the grief counselors,
or the drug counselors,
or all of those different things
that we all know would help in community.
And so, one thing I think is very clear is
if we just approach public safety
with this police only perspective
that we have for so long,
to me that's like
approaching public health
with an ambulance only perspective, right?
We know how ridiculous that would be
to just chase problems after it happens.
We have to start investing in families
and in neighborhoods to try
to reduce the likelihood
that something bad is gonna
happen in the first place,
so it starts with, we hear
our police officers saying
we can't be the mental health counselors
and the social workers
and the drug counselors.
All of those things,
they're taking orders.
Like those are things that
we're clearly identifying
a need for, so we ought
to invest in those things.
We know, Conan, I'm guessing you live
in a safe neighborhood, right?
I do, yeah.
And I would guess that
in your neighborhood,
you have strong schools.
I would guess that folks have
access to really good jobs.
I would guess that folks have the ability
to kinda make their money work for them,
and live a quality life,
and so if we're just investing money
to hire people to chase
problems after they happen,
then that's the opposite
of investing to transform,
our most challenged neighborhoods
into those neighborhoods that have
the kind of social capital
that your neighborhoods have,
and that's, I think, at the core
of what people are asking for.
It feels to me, 'cause
I'm familiar that you
do want more community involvement,
and it sounds to me, and
it makes a lot of sense
that you're advocating
a more nuanced approach,
meaning it's not just police,
you take care of everything.
It's trying to figure out
what situations should we
not be sending the police
in to handle, but be sending someone else
in to handle, is that correct?
That's exactly right.
Any gun safety instructor,
or any police officer
would tell you that even if you're
a good guy with good intentions,
just introducing a gun,
introducing a firearm into a situation
inherently makes that
situation dangerous, right?
And so when people have
a mental health crisis,
there's a number of
reasons people call 911.
Sometimes it's because I'm being robbed
and I need an officer to show up.
Sometimes it's because I'm in crisis.
Sometimes it's because I just
need help with something,
and we need to figure out
how to bring different levels
of resource to kinda meet those needs.
That's something that we're doing,
I think very well in St. Paul.
We have a chief, Conan, who
is constantly focused on
what he calls making
deposits in our bank of trust
with our community members.
I hear him ask our officers
after anything happens three questions.
Were your actions reasonable,
were they necessary, and
were they done with respect?
And if you can answer yes to
all three of those questions,
then you're probably gonna have
a relatively quick, short
conversation with our chief.
If you can't answer
yes to those questions,
reasonable, necessary, and respectful,
then you're gonna have a longer
conversation with our chief.
We've engaged community
members in the process
of defining what public
safety means for us,
and what those types of investments are,
and we're actually already
walking down that road.
We have actually already launched
a public health, mental
health co-responder model
where we have social workers
trained in mental health
who are literally in the police car
riding along with police officers
to respond to some of
those issues that we know
won't be solved by just showing
up and arresting somebody,
but needs a longer term approach.
We're doing that work and
we want to do more of it,
and I think it's important to
see the rest of the country
do some of that as well.
It's hard for me,
because of what you said,
not to remember that
the reason Philando Castile was killed,
unnecessarily, shockingly killed,
was that all he did was tell the officer
I do have a weapon in the car
and I'm licensed to carry,
and he was saying that
to create more safety
and to be responsible.
Tragically, the officer
said you're holding a gun.
Don't bring out the gun, and he wasn't,
and didn't, but ended up getting shot,
that introducing police
and people with weapons
into every situation obviously
can make that situation instantaneously
a thousand times more
dangerous and volatile,
and so the idea that you could have
different types of people responding
in different levels of need
makes a lot of sense.
I know that this leads into an initiative
called Eight Can't Wait, and it has--
There's so much of it, I read through
the Eight Can't Wait program,
and obviously there's things in there
that say well, listen, no
more use of choke holds,
no more clamping down on an airway
or the carotid because
that is so dangerous
and can go so wrong so quickly,
but then there's so many
other initiatives in there
that once I read them
made intuitive sense,
which was about creating distance,
creating a bunch of parameters
that would make the situation much safer.
Can you talk about some of those
initiatives from Eight Can't Wait?
Yeah, without a doubt.
The first thing you said, Conan,
I think brought together
a number of the things
that we're talking about.
In that, Philando Castile
just being himself,
and having a firearm, even
though it was in his pocket
and put away and he's
talking about it directly
to let the officer know that it was there
out of courtesy, that just
being himself was a threat.
That officer considered him a threat
just sitting there being himself,
and therein lies, I think,
a big part of the problem is.
If the standard by which we determine
whether somebody can be held accountable
for taking a life is whether
you feel threatened or not,
and if my very existence, if my oxygen
makes you feel threatened,
well then it's easy to see
why people all across this
country say wait a minute.
We have to assert the value of black lives
in a different way.
That's really critical.
My father was a St. Paul police
officer, you mentioned that.
He served almost three decades,
and I would see him just
go through our community
solving problems and
identifying problems that
if you're not from our neighborhood,
you probably wouldn't even know
was a problem in the first place,
and so he was able to serve
our community in ways that
other officers just could not,
that nobody else really could
because he's from here,
because he grew up here.
He was raising his children here.
He goes to the grocery store,
he goes to church here,
and he's interwoven as
a part of the community.
And so we have, and I
always hear my father say,
he goes when you're that
much a part of the community
and when somebody's kids go
to school with your kids,
or you grew up with their parents,
or you're that interwoven together,
instead of looking for justifiable reasons
to use deadly force, you
can find an unlimited
number of reasons not to use deadly force,
not to shoot somebody,
not to kill somebody.
So we've signed up for this
Eight Can't Wait campaign,
and it's about rewriting
our use of force policies.
The truth is we did that when
we first came into office.
Unfortunately, I think the saddest thing
about George Floyd's murder
is how historically unsurprising it is.
We've been on this road
for quite some time,
and we are where we've gotten
as a result of kinda the
road that we've been on.
And so this was a priority of mine
when we first came into office.
I think in the first two
or three months in office
we had a two-month
public engagement process
to engage our community in
what our use of force policy should be.
I don't know of--
I don't know of any police department,
any agency on the planet
before us, frankly,
that has engaged community members to say
let's come up with an agreement.
What's our compact on what
our use of force policies should be
for our police officers?
The final policy that
we passed two years ago
includes dozens, I think a couple dozen
of suggestions that we got
straight from community members
and I think that's really important.
So the truth is with that
Eight Can't Wait campaign,
most of those things are things
that we actually already
implemented two years ago.
We wanted to make sure that
there was an explicit--
You know, that we explicitly addressed
two of the items that the
campaign kinda identified
as not specifically
addressed in our policy,
so our chief did a fantastic job
and got that turned around,
I think within 24 hours of realizing
that they had alerted
us to this challenge.
But in the end, our policy,
which I think is very important,
it does a number of things.
It establishes that duty
to deescalate a situation.
It establishes the duty to intervene
that we've all talked
about and seen on display
as necessary in the past week.
It changes from where we always
talk about reasonable force.
It directs our officers to utilize
the minimum amount of force necessary,
the minimal amount of force,
both reasonable and necessary,
so not just reasonable.
The question is was it
necessary in that situation?
And I think pretty intriguingly,
it distinguishes between
how officers respond
to people who are
being sort of passively resistant,
just saying I'm not gonna
get up when you say get up,
versus people who are being
aggressive toward an officer
or toward another human being.
The way we respond to them
has to be fundamentally different.
It feels to me that there's
a lot of this, sadly,
that is, it's kind of common sense.
It is, yeah.
You and I are both human beings.
I've been in the world
a lot longer than you,
but I know just being on this planet
that when you treat someone
like an other,
you are going to get
that same feeling back.
When you get to know people,
when you talk to them,
when you ask them how you're doing
and you show any amount of empathy,
you are creating a
contract, a social contract,
and these are things that we all know,
we all know, but I think
it's something in our wiring.
We can forget it or we
can drift away from it,
so obviously when an officer
is being sent into a situation
where for whatever reason
he feels threatened
or is tense or something,
he might flip over, there's that circuit
that flips over into
this person is the other.
That's right.
Rather than seeing it
as this is someone I may know,
someone from my community who
I have had experience with
because I've been part of the community.
I think that's where the notion
that you've been talking about to use
community policing more,
and I want to use that word carefully
because obviously police
officers have to be
highly, highly trained, but
make sure that the community is involved
in keeping their community safe,
and that they have some of the power
and experience to do that.
I think there's no other way around that.
My father wrote a book about growing up,
and I don't want to
spoil it for you, Conan,
'cause I'm sure you've
got it on your list, but--
I will have it on my list.
Yeah, I will.
That's right, that's right.
There's a part of it where he talks about
when he was 25 and two
of his closest cousins
and best friends in life were murdered
in a double homicide, and
they were his closest friends.
They had grown up together
and somewhere along the way
they had taken a pact
that if somebody kills you
I'll kill them, right?
And it's kind of this situation where
the whole neighborhood assumes
my father's gonna go after this guy,
and he ends up getting
acquitted for the killing
and disappears right after it,
and my father found out years later,
probably decades later,
that my grandfather had
approached the suspect's mother
and had paid for him
to have a train ticket
or a bus ticket out of town,
and that's an example, I think,
of community working together, right,
of community identifying a problem,
community kinda stepping in and saying
this could go wrong in a way
that's bad for all of us,
and let's work together to create
community level solutions,
so that's one of the things
that we're investing in as well,
and there's a number of
communities around the country
and around the world
who are having success
with hiring community
members, hiring neighbors
as interveners and interrupters
to identify these kind of things
that could go really bad in the community
and figure out how, based
on community resources,
using community, the
language of community,
how to interrupt and help prevent violence
from happening in the first place,
and I think that's the core of what
many of us are saying, right?
Instead of this public safety strategy,
instead of this kind of
framework and toolbox
that all waits to start
until after a crime has been committed...
Right, right.
How do we invest proactively
in our neighbors?
in our neighborhood areas?
How do we invest
proactively in our families
and our children in such a way
that makes people less likely
to have to act out in desperation?
It's really, it's preventative health.
That's what it is.
Versus chemotherapy,
and I think that's I think what
I'm hoping this movement,
this turmoil and this anguish,
and this activism leads to
is a sense that everybody knows
you don't want to wait to the stage where
you're getting chemotherapy.
That's right.
You want to
take care of yourself and we want to
take care of our community and
the people in our community
so they all feel invested.
That's right.
And you know what I would say, Conan,
is right now we have the language for it
because as we know well,
we're in four different crises
at the same time right now.
We have the pandemic, the
physical health portion of it,
we have the economic
portion of the pandemic,
we have the trauma, the
triggered historic trauma
of the video of George Floyd's murder,
and now we have the rebuilding
that so many cities around
the country have to do
after all the destruction that's happened
in the last couple of weeks,
and so we're facing all of
these things at the same time.
But one of the things
that the COVID-19 pandemic
has given us is a language
around this, right?
We've got this pandemic and Conan,
we've been talking about
violence as a public health,
you know, every time we have a shooting,
or every time we have an incident,
somebody gets on TV and says
this is a public health crisis.
And I agree with that,
but we haven't really started
to employ on any large scale
public health solutions to it yet.
The pandemic has given us
the language of testing
so that we know who's impacted, right,
so that we know who's
impacted by this thing.
It's given us the language of treatment,
so that once we identify who's impacted,
we have to do something to figure out
how to intervene and help them heal
from this ailment, and it's given us
the language of contact tracing to say
who else might you have
touched with this, right?
And the interesting thing that
a bunch of epidemiologists
and people smarter than me
figured out is that violence
acts like an epidemic.
Violence does act like
a public health crisis
in that in the same ways we can predict
a case of the flu by
having been around someone
with a case of the flu,
the best predictor of
an incident of violence
is a preceding incident of violence,
and so when we think about employing
exactly what you just described,
this public health lens to this,
it creates a whole new--
It opens a set of doors and
a whole new toolbox for us
because if we start
identifying that testing
to say who's been impacted by violence,
who's most likely to be
touched by the ailments of
violence in our communities,
to treat it and say how do we intervene,
whether that's the mental health,
whether that's supportive resources,
whether that's peer to peer counseling,
how do we intervene to help
kind of break that cycle,
and who have they been in touch with?
How do we do the contact tracing
to help identify, isolate,
and slow this pandemic?
That to me seems to be
the smartest toolkit.
It's working in cities around the country.
That's what we're on the starting lines
in implementing here in St. Paul,
and that seems a lot more effective
and frankly a lot more research based
than just saying oh, we don't feel safe
so we're gonna put another
billions of dollars into the police,
prosecutors and prisons.
This week and a half that
we've just experienced
doesn't just pass away
as so many things in our culture do.
We have such a short attention span,
and we tend to move from crisis to crisis
or whatever's trending,
and we don't want this situation
to be something that trended
for a couple of weeks
and then went away without
there being lasting change.
Are you optimistic?
I would like to be optimistic that,
because this does feel different.
I was too young in 1968 to experience
that upheaval.
This does feel, in my lifetime, 57 years,
it's the biggest thing that I've witnessed
and my hope is that it's lasting.
Do you feel this could be lasting,
that if we keep doing the work,
that people will stay focused
and this could lead us to a better place?
I am hopeful about that, and I'll tell you
one of the amazing
things that I've learned
is just to bet on the human spirit,
and that every time something just
horrifically ugly happens in community
that we see this beautiful
human spirit show up
and so in St. Paul and in
many of the other cities
around the country where we've seen just
massive, heartbreaking
levels of destruction,
and Conan, I want to be really clear,
and I think you've spoken to this already,
there's sort of two things.
There were the protestors, right,
and by protestors I mean the people
who just are heartbroken
by George Floyd's loss,
just feel it's unjust and that
he should still be alive today,
the people who feel
like these four officers
must be held accountable in court,
all four of them, not just the one,
and feel like we just
have this soul searching,
deep work to do as a country
to stop this cycle from
happening over and over again.
So there's the protestors, but then
there's also the rioters,
the people who showed up
to break a window, and to
light a building on fire,
and to just create
destruction in community.
And so when I'm talking
about that kind of,
that violence and destruction that we saw,
those rioters, who clearly
could not have been driven
by just a sense of a need for more justice
and fairness while stripping our neighbors
of their ability to make a living
or our senior citizens of their ability
to go to the corner and get
their lifesaving medicine
from their pharmacy in
the middle of a pandemic,
all that to say is when the
sun came up the next morning,
it came up on neighbors just
coming out of the woodworks
with shovels and brooms
and bags and trash cans.
We were sitting on our block
and all of a sudden some
music came out of nowhere,
and we looked up to say
where is that coming from?
And an army of neighbors
walked up the street
just cleaning up.
I mean, it looked like a
scene from the Cat in the Hat,
like just neighbors
coming out of the woodwork
to clean up and
volunteering for each other,
don't even know each other,
just volunteering for each other.
We had a business we did a
supply drive last Saturday,
a business here whose
windows are still boarded up,
who instead of cleaning up
their own business on Saturday,
opened up their parking lot
and were collecting formula and diapers
and canned foods, and families were coming
to bring stuff and families
were coming to take stuff,
and it was just this kind of
massive sense of community.
I did a walk down one of our main streets
that was impacted earlier this week,
or I'm sorry, last week,
and you know, was looking at
businesses who were boarded up,
and passed two businesses
that were boarded up
and somebody came out and
said mayor, mayor, mayor.
And I said yes, and said
I just want you to know
from two to six p.m. today
we're feeding community
members free lunch,
and so if you know anybody who needs food,
tell them to come by
and get their food here.
And there are no shortage of those stories
where people are just
taking care of each other.
The business owner whose building
was literally burned to the ground
and she stopped me to say my business
was burned to the ground.
I said I know and I'm really sorry.
We're gonna help you
rebuild, and she said no,
that's not what I'm saying.
I'm saying I have time to help right now.
I want to help fundraise
for other businesses.
And I'll tell you that's the energy
that really touches me
and when we look at combining that energy
with the energy of kind
of the young people
and the people all over our country
who are out in the
streets, I think we'll find
that's the same energy
that created this country.
It's the same energy that ended slavery
and that established civil rights,
and it's the same energy that I think
is gonna carry us through
to the next chapter.
On a slightly lighter
note, I want to point out
your mother is the chair
of the County Board of Commissioners.
Yes.
So the way the government's set up,
and this really makes me smile,
for you to get anything
done or approved as mayor,
and a very influential mayor,
you have to go to your mom.
Well, not exactly, just because--
(laughing)
Conan, Conan, when I get in trouble
and when I do stuff
that people don't like,
they still go and get my mom.
They're like should we bring Mrs. Carter
into the conversation?
(laughing)
So I have a city council that I work with,
and we are the county
seat of Ramsey County,
and so we work very closely
with the county board.
I don't go to them to request
direct approval of my budgets
or anything like that.
I go to our city council, but we do
work together very closely.
I'm actually really proud
of the work that she's done,
even in this space.
She's led the process since
I think 2005 they started
of an initiative here called
Juvenile Detention
Alternatives Initiative,
which started off just saying look,
we're locking up too many young people.
We had a time where we would go through
our juvenile detention centers
and it was so packed
that there would be cots
in the hallways, 'cause
it'd be beyond capacity,
and they started investing money.
They started with a
million dollar investments
into alternatives to detention
and just figuring out
can we create evening reporting centers?
Can we send young people
home on supervised release?
What are all the different
things that we can do
instead of bringing young people
into the juvenile justice system?
It's so important because
this is an incredible fact,
but research shows that
controlling for other factors,
a young person who has spent
a night in juvenile detention
is actually more likely
to be an adult offender.
Our system is actually
making them more likely
to be offenders in the
future, not less likely.
That should be a gut check moment for us.
All that to say is they have,
through this Juvenile Detention
Alternatives Initiative,
we have reduced average daily intake
of young people in our community
by I think over 80%.
They have shut down entire wings
of that same juvenile detention center.
Just last year we closed a
place called Boys Totem Town,
which was a secure confinement facility
for young people in our community,
and we've done all of those things, Conan,
without seeing any corresponding increase
in juvenile crime in our community,
and it goes to show that
we've way over-utilized detention.
We've way over-utilized confinement,
and so we're excited for the chance
to work together on kind of
pushing this vision forward.
Well, I have to say what
an impressive family
you come from, your mom, your dad,
obviously yourself.
You guys give me a lot of hope.
I know that everybody
has to do the work now.
I had a conversation with
W. Kamau Bell last week,
and we talked about it's about the work
and it's about doing the work,
and that's not just you, that's not
just people in the black
community, it's everybody,
especially everybody.
Yes.
Everybody has to
do the work, but you
give me a lot of hope,
you and your very impressive family
and there's a lot of ways that I probably,
I don't know what it's like to be you,
but what I do know is I
do know what it's like
to have a three-month-old
and you have my sympathy.
I appreciate it, I appreciate it.
She's great.
You know, kidding aside,
she's fantastic 24 hours a day,
and I appreciate your
compliments of our family.
I didn't get a chance to tell you
about my sisters and my brother-in-laws,
and my niece who just
graduated from high school,
and my wife, who's a mid-wife,
whose birthday it is today, so--
Oh, happy birthday.
Happy birthday, sweetheart.
Yeah.
Thank you,
I appreciate that.
I'll tell her you said so.
I'm sure that'll mean the world to her.
(laughing)
It will.
It absolutely will.
So yeah, we're surrounded
by a group of good folks,
and you know, between our staff
and the city workers and the
police and the firefighters
who just served our city with distinction
through these past couple of weeks,
I feel really blessed to be around
just a pretty incredible crew of folks.
Yeah, well, continued good luck to you
in everything that you're doing,
and if things get too rough
with the three-month-old,
I'll say it again.
You come stay at my place
until things blow over.
Absolutely.
Absolutely, if you could
just text me the directions,
I'll be over.
(laughing)
What you do is you tell the wife
I've got some business I have to do.
(laughing)
That's right.
I'll be gone until she's
about four years old
and then I'll come back.
Right.
Right, oh it'll just be a few months.
It'll just be a few
months, I'll be right back.
I've got some things, yeah.
And then hey, thank you so
much for taking the time.
I really appreciate it, and I look forward
to meeting you in person some time.
That would be very cool.
Absolutely, I appreciate you having me on,
and I appreciate the way
you're using your platform
to elevate other voices
and those stories that
haven't necessarily been told.
It's really powerful and it means a lot.
Well, it means a lot to me.
Selfishly, I'm learning a lot
and it's been a blessing and a joy for me,
so thank you very much, Mayor Carter,
and continued success to you.
I appreciate it, thanks for having me on.
All right, take care.
That was great, that was fantastic.
Yeah?
Yeah, we're done.
That was good, that was--
Awesome.
That was long, we did a lot,
so we'll see what we can get.
We're gonna have to
compress some of it for TBS,
but then all of it can go online,
which is how 99% of people see it.
Nice, nice.
Yeah, that was really terrific.
That's pretty sweet, I appreciate that.
Like I said, it's really enormous for us,
'cause these are stories that people--
I mean, these are stories that
like my great-grandparents
were telling but nobody was listening
and nobody was giving them
a microphone, you know?
Right.
And so I appreciate
you kind of opening that up.
No, no, no, it's what--
This is how to get there, I hope.
Wherever there is, it'll never be perfect,
but I'm hoping, but we can do a lot better
than what we're doing, so--
Yeah, yeah.
We definitely can.
Be well today, all right?
I heard you were planning on coming
and doing a live remote from St. Paul.
Can I help you set that up?
If we do a live remote
from St. Paul, I'll do it.
There hasn't been--
Because of COVID, no one's
been getting on a plane.
That's been the big issue for us.
True, very.
I'd love to come to St. Paul
if we can figure it out,
and a safe way to do it,
and it'd be nice to meet.
It'd be nice to talk.
I'd love that too.
Well, when we open stuff back up,
there's other people on this call.
It's being recorded, so that's
I think as good as a binding
contract in some countries.
You'd be shocked at how
slippery I am, you know?
I am a slippery--
(laughing)
Right.
You know,
I say anything and then you know,
I just disappear for years at a time.
No, I really would, it
would be a honor to meet you
and to grab a meal, and then
if we can figure out a
good piece to do with it
that would be fantastic.
All right, that'd be ama--
I'd definitely be down for that,
so I appreciate it.
When you're ready, I'm ready.
All right, if you can handle me in person.
It's a lot to take in.
I'm told I am as well, so
we'll see what happens.
I'm told a resemble a
very tall Belgian woman,
so just be ready for that.
I have never been told that.
(laughing)
Hey, thank you so much, take care.
All right, thanks a lot.
Have a great rest of the day.
You too.
All right, bye.